Writing completely revolutionized humanity
in almost every way.
We can tweet, write scripts, and … well
that's really it, right?
Language makes it so everything we do, works,
right?
Without language, I couldn't talk to you or
tell you to watch out for that predator!
To put it simply, language allows me to express
what's in here [head] out here.
And that's hugely powerful, it's life-changing.
It's WORLD changing.
According to modern archeology, there may
have been proto-language as far back as homo
erectus and homo habilis more than a million
years ago, but our first true verbal language
probably developed between 30,000 and 100,000
years ago.
So if verbal language lets me tell someone
next to me what's inside my head, writing
lets me tell someone 500 miles away, or 500
years from now.
Writing was a major world-changing invention.
First with symbols, cave paintings and pictograms,
a new study from a Canadian researcher believes
this proto-written language may be 40,000
years old.
The researcher looked at cave symbols across
Southern Europe and found symbols repeated,
indicating to her there was likely some kind
of writing system in use.
There were even memes, where some symbols
rose and fell in popularity, indicating an
overarching interest and culture.
But what they meant is a mystery, because
there's no context.
Most archaeologists believe the first true
writing was cuneiform.
It was developed in ancient Sumer around 3000
BCE, as an evolution of tiny pictograms, it
eventually had enough contextual information
to closely mimic what people were actually
saying!
It was created by pressing a blunt reed into
a piece of clay allowing it to be preserved
for later perusal.
Modern humans with their reading, writing,
and… well pretty much that's what they had
at the time -- were able to spread throughout
Europe and Africa.
But language does more than facilitate expression,
storytelling and coordination…
When you write, your brain has to navigate
those fine motor movements; recall letters,
words, shapes, and rules; not to mention simply
seeing what's on the paper, reading and comprehending
what you've written -- AND predicting what
you're going to write next.
Functional MRI scans done on the brains of
writers during a study from the University
of Greifswald found brain activity similar
to that of a professional sports star.
Using a custom-built writing desk, the researchers
allowed people to write creatively while assessing
their brain's blood flow, and found visual
and speech centers lit up during brainstorming,
the hippocampus activated during factual recollection,
and the prefrontal cortex was active, possibly
to keep the storylines, characters and details
straight while committing it to paper.
Our brains light up all OVER during the act
of writing; and over time, with practice,
parts of the brain learn to automate some
of those processes.
We don't have to practice making an A after
a while we just know how to do it automatically.
Our BRAINS have been altered, for the better
-- one could argue -- by writing!
Communicating with each other completely changed
human history, allowing us to expand across
the globe and share our best ideas.
According to Gallup polling, we read more
now than in the last 70 years (thanks internet!)!
And as emojis and gifs invade our written
communication, writing is still evolving…
A study in Emotional Neuroscience found our
brains process emoji's tiny little faces as
actual faces.
So, is the future of writing the past of writing?
Are we going back to pictograms?
Do you hand-write ANYTHING anymore?
I try to, but it's really tough for my pen
and paper to keep up with my brain…